depuis l'âge de 7-8 ans j'ai passé ma
vie entière à prier tous les jours force
de bordels de mourir jeune
c'est bien raté se voir mourir c'est une
rencontre longtemps attendu avec un ami
bonsoir à tous dans l'actualité que nous
vous présentons tous les soirs il y à
des hommages de circonstance
et il ya les autres depuis ce matin
c'est une émotion et un respect profond
qu'on sent monter de tout le pays la
france est touchée au coeur a dit
jacques chirac nous l'entendrons et une
large partie de cette édition sera
consacré à la disparition de l'abbé
pierre qui aura droit à un hommage
national vendredi
d'abord les faits l'abbé avait 94 ans il
était très diminué depuis plusieurs mois
aurélia guillemin lionel feierstein la
dernière apparition publique de l'abbé
pierre
c'était le 5 janvier dernier lors des
voeux de jacques chirac aux forces vives
de la nation digne mais déjà très
affaibli ce jour là il s'était à 5h25 ce
matin l'hôpital du val-de-grâce des
suites d'une infection pulmonaire
on est assez détériorer pendant les
pendant le week-end et puis pendant les
derniers d'erreurs qu'il est mort de son
âge puis de 7,1 de cette affection
hospitalisé depuis huit jours pour une
bronchite qui a dégénéré son entourage a
longtemps cru qu'il résisterait à ce
nouveau combat mais cette nuit entourées
de quelques proches
il a récité sa dernière prière il
murmuré un je vous salue marie et
célèbre n'arrivait plus à dire les
paroles mais c'est continuer de lui
murmurer au moment où il s'éteint avec
beaucoup de douceur
deux heures après sa mort déjà des
anonymes se pressaient devant les
grilles de l'hôpital
on vient déposer une fleur se recueillir
exprimé son émotion souvent vives face à
la disparition d'un être cher
le regard est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
et ça me touche beaucoup et c'est un
grand bravo bravo pour tout ce qu'il a
fait il serait mais tout le temps tout
le temps le peloton roule même la une et
on les bras toujours à la mairie
d'alfortville où l'abbé pierre résider
depuis trois ans un registre permet
aujourd'hui aux habitants de venir
consignes et quelques mots de
condoléances
quand je me souviens ce matin ça m'a
fait de la peine quand des gens comme il
y en a pour du court très ému de sa
perte et
j'espère qu'on aura tous la force de
continuer ce qu'il entreprend
témoignage de tristesse d'admiration et
surtout de remerciement jusque devant
les portes de son dernier domicile d
hommage simple à l'image de l'homme qui
s'était peint à 94 ans oui l'émotion
elle entendra tout au long de ce journal
est à la mesure du personnage et de son
parcours hors du commun
henri grouès de son vrai nom avait été
résistant députés à la libération
mais c'est bien sûr son cri son appel de
1954 qui le fera entrer dans la légende
évocation signé laetitia legendre c'est
au coeur d'un hiver glacial que naît la
légende de la vespière 1954 une femme
expulsée de son logement ainsi qu'un
bébé meurt dans la rue le froid alors
retenti sur radio luxembourg la voie
d'un dénommé henri grouès c'est l'abbé
pierre ils ans l'insurrection la beauté
il faut que ce soir même dans toutes les
villes de france
des pancartes s'accroche où l'on lise
c'est simplement toi qui souffrent qui
que tu sois entre dort mange reprend
espoir
ici on t'aime l'appel déclenché une
vague de solidarité sans précédent
les français découvrent qu'un tiers
d'entre eux vit sans eau sans
électricité
nous avons été comme emportée par un
vent de tempête un vent de bonté qui
faisait que devant la souffrance nous
changions et notre coeur est et meyer ne
donnions cet épisode contrat les
politiques à agir
il débloque les milliards nécessaires à
la construction de logements pour les
sans abri une vie de résistant au propre
comme au figuré car des 42 il prend le
maquis dans le vercors des soupes des
juifs avec l'aide de religieuses j'étais
dire ça voilà j'ai deux types qu'est-ce
que j'en fais et la mercière m'a dit on
veut tu as bien voulait pendre mais on
en a déjà plein dans le couvent et si on
en prend davantage c'est trop dangereux
mais le dc comics mais c'est comme ça je
vais appeler la petite soeur sue plus
commun et elle va vous apprendre à
falsifier la signature du commissaire de
police
on a des papiers en blanc et on va vous
allez vous allez apprendre à fabriquer
des tampons et de fausses identités
puis le voit la députée de meurthe et
moselle avant de filer emmaüs en 43
cents ce qui la confondent avec le
surpeuplement de locaux existants est
trop exigu la communauté essaimera dans
une trentaine de pays sous la bannière
d'emmaüs international avec les années
80 apparaissent ce que l'on appelle
alors les nouveaux pauvres
l'abbé repart en croisade fnesi n'est
plus tout seul ça va bien tout ça
relance qui dès quoi que vous aviez
lancé qu'il faut être généreux les uns
avec les autres et on a fait faire une
loi est ouvert de l'argent aux côtés des
squatteurs de la rue du dragon sur le
quai de la gare il est de tous les
combats ont fait leur descente à pied
des sans-logis décembre au soc son
omniprésence en fait l'incontournable
apôtre des causes perdues
sa fidélité ignore les limites à tel
point qu'en 96 il apporte son soutien à
l'historien roger garaudy accusé de
négationnisme
la réprobation unanime jusque dans les
rangs d'emmaüs le conduite à demander
pardon
puis à s'exiler dans un couvent en
italien en fait c'était de tout gratos
c'est celle il inculpe coeuret
historiquement violent dit monsieur
combien de fois avez vous risquez votre
vue pour quelqu'un moi pendant deux ans
j'ai risqué ma vie quasiment tous les
humains pour sauver autant que j'ai pu
on peut de ces persécutés dont on
prétend que de filles
un raciste antisémite il se fait un
devoir de s'enflammer
radio télé presse écrite qu'importe le
moyen ce qui compte c'est d'interpeller
les politiques sur le sort des plus
démunis
et jeudi la politique ça consiste
uniquement à savoir à qui on va prendre
du fric et abyan balle donnée en juin
2005 il accède à la dignité de
grand'croix de la légion d'honneur
mais dans son esprit il est déjà en
partance pour les grandes vacances
c'est ainsi qu'il désigne la mort pour
moi la mort ce n'est pas une séparation
c'est une continuation ce n'est pas une
fin mais un renouveau
c'est comme sortir de l'ombre pour
entrer dans la lumière
il disait vouloir mourir jeune il aura
vécu presque un siècle
s'il fallait de son héritage ne retenir
qu'un principe ce serait celui qu'il a
exprimé toute sa vie il ne faut pas
faire la guerre aux pauvres mais à la
pauvreté
huit ans paf c'est la silhouette devant
l'hôpital du val de grâce on retrouve
loïc de la mornais loïc l'abbé pierre
aura droit aux hommages réservé aux plus
grands avec plusieurs jours de
recueillement
oui david jacques chirac avait le choix
entre un deuil national qui est la plus
haute cérémonie qui soit et qui
s'accompagne d'un jour férié donc
d'administration fermés ou bien d'un
hommage national qui est la cérémonie on
va dire entre guillemets juste en
dessous c'est donc cette dernière option
qui a été retenue
il y aura donc un hommage national comme
ça a été le cas après par exemple la
mort du commandant cousteau ou encore du
pape jean paul ii alors cette semaine
s'accompagnera donc de très nombreux
hommages tous les jours mercredi et
jeudi ici au val de grâce le corps de
l'abbé pierre sera exposée dans une
chapelle
le public pourra venir lui rendre
hommage de 10h à 22h à son gré donc
mercredi jeudi de 10h à 22h ici jeudi il
y aura également une grande
commémoration à l'organisation avec
l'organisation de l'association emmaüs
au palais omnisports de paris bercy
et puis donc vendredi cette grande
journée d'hommage national avec une
messe en la cathédrale notre dame à 11
heures vendredi matin
jacques chirac y assistera en compagnie
d'une grande partie du gouvernement et
puis un petit peu plus tard l'abbé
pierre sera enterrée dans la plus
stricte intimité
en seine-maritime dans le petit village
d'esteville l'abbé pierre n'avait pas
d'attachés familiales particulières dans
cette région mais
l'association emmaüs possède une
concession dans le petit cimetière
d'esteville où reposent déjà plusieurs
compagnons d'emmaüs
et puis juste pour vous dire que quand
on posait la question à la vespière de
savoir quelle épitaphe il souhaitait
voir sur sa tombe
il avait proposé celle ci il a essayé
d'aimer
merci loïc je vous précise que vous
pourrez suivre cette cérémonie à
notre-dame de paris vendredi en direct
sur notre antenne à partir de 10h30
l'abbé pierre on l'a entendu il ya un
instant ne craignez pas la mort ils
l'attendaient même depuis quelques temps
je vous propose l'une de ses dernières
interviews c'était en avril 2005 il y à
un peu plus d'un an et demi une
interview accordée à nabila taboury et
guillaume michel depuis seul l'art de
7,8
j'ai passé ma vie entière prier tous les
jours pour déborder de mourir jeune
c'est bien rater j'arrive à 93 ans et
avec une chose mais très vite il
aujourd'hui à des voeux à vous lui avez
cassé les oreilles par didier mary
hudson mary il veut je veux prendre au
piège
ça va durer combien de temps je reste là
meurent par mois m'apparaît comme une
des fleurs de la vie ça fait partie de
la vie c'est un homme en 1/2 faire que
ça ne soit pas dans la douleur que me
moins possible donc je n'ai aucune gêne
et de la mort de mon père de ma mère qui
mouraient simplement de la personne qui
pendant 32 ans
vinci cède en lui les développements du
mouvement des communautés d'emmaüs
je n'ai jamais eu de chagrin
deux heures me rire ce qui m'était très
cher mais parce que j'ai envie de dire
d'une part
ouf via des fardeaux on a eu à porter
pendant toute sa vie et puis d'autre
part je veux la foi a fait que je suis
certain je sais c'est la pleine lumière
tous ceux qui ont connu ou approché
l'abbé pierre le dise il émanait de lui
une grande humilité et une force
singulière le public le sentait c'est
pourquoi sans doute il était devenu le
personnage le plus populaire de france
d'après les sondages réaction rassemblés
aujourd'hui par karine comazzi et
mathias second avec nos équipes et nos
bureaux en région sur le parvis de notre
dame de la garde
un marseillais qui s'en allaient prier
la bonne mère apprend la mort de l'abbé
pierre choc fait un choc sur le web
parce que je ne savais pas et partout en
france la nouvelle se répand au fond de
ses filets ce pêcheur marseillais égrène
ses souvenirs il payé baiser beaucoup la
voulait pas
dès que je veux pour ce personnage ces
mots résidence qui vient oui c'est vrai
qu'on est toujours très égoïste en
société de présent plus qui fait place à
l'individu seul c'est un bon exemple à
suivre tout le monde par un jour oui je
trouve qu'il a laissé derrière lui c'est
énorme
il a donné sa vie aux autres parce qu'il
avait donné sa vie à dieu également
croyant ou athée bourgeois ou sdf l'abbé
pierre a su faire l'unanimité
ce matin ses compagnons parisiens se
sentent abandonnés on a perdu un père
quoi c'est pas pas quelqu'un qui vous
procure vous qui vous prend qui vous
écoute qui vous est ce qui qui vous
oriente l'abbé pierre a beaucoup servi
l'humanité c'est bien
et pour ça il peut être admis au
paraître quai de jemmapes le combat des
enfants de don quichotte continue au nom
du père
il avait merci beaucoup il a fait
beaucoup de choses pour nous mais c'est
à lui aussi
c'est le compact qui fait les combats
taurins c'est pas avant l'idéologie même
je crois que c'est le combat c'est la
constatation de la justice qui doit nous
faire se mouvoir vers une idée de la
justice mais qui prendra la relève
la tâche semble immense comme ce vide
laissé par l'abbé c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui avait refusé la légion
d'honneur
donc c'était quand même quelqu'un qui
était resté très hommes les ça ça peut
être dur à trouver de nos jours oui
malheureusement la société je pense que
il n'y avait pas besoin en bientôt
rendre une personne qui incarne la
relève
la relève est le devenir de tout le
monde ce soir les français se retrouvent
seuls face à leurs préoccupations
terrestres
quant à la baie il est heureux là où
alors je suis ravi pour lui bernard
kouchner est avec nous sur ce plateau
bonsoir bernard kouchner vous le
connaissiez très bien vos parcours on
était parallèle pendant des années et
des années est-ce que vous avez le
souvenir de votre première rencontre
avec l'abbé pierre 68 20 68 ou 69
une première réunion ou manifestation la
mutualité en faveur des enfants du
biafra qui qui mouraient par dizaines de
milliers nous revenions du biafra avant
de fonder médecins sans frontières
l'abbé pierre était au premier rang et
depuis nous nous sommes pas quittés
vous avez même fait un livre avec lui en
1993 dieu et les hommes dieu les hommes
c'est un titre ambitieux alors vous avez
à cette occasion beaucoup parlé avec lui
beaucoup échangé avec lui
qu'en reste-t-il pour vous l'exemple
d'une ferveur constructive
cet hommage incroyable cette impression
de d'unité nationale tant cherché dans
notre pays qui étonne hors de nos
frontières
une aventure fois dans votre reportage
le père et moi je n'aimais pas appeler
les curés mon père je trouvais que
c'était réservé à mon propre père
georges et bien comme nous alors comment
appelez-vous est bien aussi c'est un des
débats de ce livre oui je l'appelais mon
père
et puis je le tutoyaient j'étais un des
rares parce que nous créions à propos de
l'aide apportée par dieu ou des
difficultés à porter par dieu et surtout
des difficultés lorsqu'on ne croient pas
en dieu de continuer une tâche comme la
sienne ou comme la nôtre il aimait le
débat il aimait changer ce qui retient
l'attention aussi c'est que l'abbé
pierre avait tout compris au monde
moderne aux ressorts du monde et
notamment rôle des média radio photo
puis télévision il en a beaucoup joué et
fait par ses coups de colère qu'il s'est
rendu célèbre et qui l'a inspiré aussi
ses héritiers nicolas lemarignier
fatigué mais toujours combatif en
janvier 2006 l'abbé pierre est à
l'assemblée pour défendre la loi qui
oblige les municipalités à construire
des logements sociaux peu mais en
défiant l'honneur de la france ne sait
quand le fort
s'appeler le moins fort et chose est le
dernier d'une longue série de coups de
gueule qu'on ne vienne jamais de dire
que pour des tubes france comme celle-là
ça coûte très cher c'est intolérable
pour moi c'est la guerre c'est la guerre
pour paris pour la france mais si on
avait du temps je montrerai commencé la
guerre pour l'humanité toute entière la
guerre contre la misère ordre la misère
l'abbé pierre ne craint pas de s'en
prendre aux gouvernants en novembre 2002
à propos des gitans de choisy le roi il
interpelle directement le ministre de
l'intérieur nicolas sarkozy lé boire et
de manger vous qu'est ce que vous feriez
si c'était vous qui étaient condamnées à
vivre pl1 avait aux côtés des pauvres
gens
au milieu des années 90 le fondateur
d'emmaüs soutient l'association droit au
logement le dal qui occupent des
appartements vides en france iter des
coupables
ce qui dans la nécessité d'éviter la fal
a dit être la mort à des bébés à des
petits enfants dès leur peau vacants
aujourd'hui les héritiers de l'abbé
pierre ce sont eux les militants du dal
bien décidé à continuer la lutte me sous
l'ère du dragon il nous l'avait dit
clairement que vous devez apprendre à
faire sombre je pense qu'aujourd'hui
c'est des gouvernants qui vont apprendre
à faire sans la vespière et sur une
responsabilité et on attend d'eux qu'ils
nous fassent une vraie loi pour le droit
au logement
les héritiers ils sont aussi au bord du
canal saint martin les enfants de don
quichotte sont devenus les orphelins de
l'abbé pierre
encore aujourd'hui un travail énorme à
faire on continue la lutte nous on est
ici sur le terrain pour porter le
discours de la bible serre et puis les
héritiers se sont tous les compagnons
d'emmaüs et les bénévoles qui donnent
leur temps et leurs forces pour aider
les plus démunis
bernard kouchner vous dit l'abbé pierre
a inventé la loi du tapage
oui nous a enseigné la loi du tapage
vous voyez comme il se met en colère
c'est extraordinaire de se mettre en
colère avec tant de bonté et il ya des
successeurs bien sûr mais il faut pas
oublier le travail des gens qui autour
de lui ont créé toutes ces associations
nationales et internationales qu'est ce
qu'il reste de ce rebelle
finalement il nous a dit un homme peut
tout changer un homme peut changer le
monde
alors deux trois quatre une association
la société civile sans mettre en cause
la politique en titillant la politique
en forçant les polyols des lois sont
restés soirée bien sûr ils demandaient
ils intervenaient nombre des tas de gens
pour apporter grâce à sa connaissance
des hommes et du milieu gouvernemental
il a été un député du mrp après après la
guerre il ne refusait pas la politique
avait pas de séparation pour lui il
forçait la politique à l'écouté il était
capable de convaincre de forcer les
hommes et les femmes politiques avec le
poids d'une population qui l'a toujours
suivi et vous savez j'allais le voir à
esteville et puis dans l'est dans les
couvents où il prenait des périodes de
retraite et dans ses couvents ne parlait
pas alors nous étions en face l'un de
l'autre parfois ou à côté l'un de
l'autre on n'a pas droit de parler il ya
quelqu'un qui lit des textes religieux
et je le regardais et par dessus mon
échangeait des petits clins d'oeil il
était un rebelle il n'était pas un
révolutionnaire
il n'était pas non plus un élève de cils
de l'église il a contesté auprès du pape
il est venu parler du préservatif et le
sida et cetera voilà c'était un homme
avec des passions humaines d amour
humaine et une expérience de tendresse
formidable merci bernard kouchner
depuis ce matin c'est une avalanche de
réactions qui salue cette disparition
ému attristé mais surtout reconnaissante
un tel consensus est assez rare écoutez
d'abord le président la république pour
qui la france est touchée au coeur mais
pierre nous a montré la voie du coeur de
la générosité de l'esprit de révolte
service
des plus vulnérables son message doit
rester présent en chacun de nous et
c'est à nous tous de le faire vivre
c'est à nous tous de nous rassembler
pour donner tout leur sens aux valeurs
de justice et de fraternité qui sont en
fait le ciment même de notre patrie
réaction également des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle on écoute dans
l'ordre ségolène royal nicolas sarkozy
françois bayrou et marie george buffet
sans combat reste toujours d'actualité
on le voit au cours de cet hiver 2007 et
donc je crois que ce cri doit rester
vivant les sans logis ne doivent pas se
sentir orphelin juge tient beaucoup à
saluer à la fois le combat de l'abbé
pierre pour la dignité humaine et pour
le logement de tous mais également la
piété et la foi de cet homme c'est
quelqu'un qui acceptaient pas
l'injustice et qui s'est battu toute sa
vie contre l'injustice et en même temps
il avait dans le regard une lueur
espiègle et bienveillante généreuse la
france a perdu un homme qui par son
combat sa ténacité sa persévérance a
marqué l'opinion publique est je crois
un homme qui était respectée et aimée
par beaucoup de français et françaises
réactions aussi bien sûr de jean-louis
borloo en charge du logement au
gouvernement sa voix a été entendue dit
jean louis borloo il affirme que la loi
sur le droit au logement opposable
portera le nom de l'abbé pierre
et puis les commentaires aussi parmi les
compagnons d'emmaüs création de l'abbé
pierre il y a du chagrin vous allez
l'entendre il ya surtout des souvenirs
et de la fierté
anouk burel sylvain doba c'est un
compagnon de toujours un de ceux que
l'on appelait chiffonniers dans les
années 50 il revient aujourd'hui l'âme
en peine dans cette maison de l'abbé
pierre
il y avait qu si longtemps dans l'ombre
du grand art je suis ému bouleversé en
sachant que vous lui fait gagner comme
il l'a dit souvent maintenant c'est les
grandes vacances
mais il me manque que c'est une manque
énormément de gens comme vous le savez
joseph cojean a rejoint la maison mère
en 1959
dix ans après son ouverture par l'abbé
pierre une vocation née de l'appel de
l'hiver 54
à l'époque il n'avait pas 20 ans
aujourd'hui c'est un compagnon triste
qui a perdu un père avec lequel il a
tout bâti années soixante années 70 me
et souvenirs se bousculent autour de
cette table où tous ont rencontré un
jour leur a dit ça a été une
personnalité exceptionnelle que je
n'oublierai jamais à moins de son goût
est dans la merde je ne peux pas
l'oublier quand il regardait le dimanche
de sa fenêtre
les compagnons à bir l'habit du dimanche
qui sortait on l'a toujours à l'esprit
maintenant dans l'esprit la bba bien sûr
c'était c'était l'image la grande image
c'était celle qui me guide est un petit
peu je voulais cette grande image a
aujourd'hui valeur de symbole le chemin
parcouru par l'abbé pierre et celui
qu'il leur reste à parcourir
après lui oui on parlait de l'héritage
il faut bien comprendre que l'abbé
pierre n'était pas seulement un
visionnaire il était soucieux
d'efficacité me entreprise me
associations les compagnons d'emmaüs qui
encourage le retour au travail sont
implantés maintenant dans le monde
entier c'est une réussite et une
référence amaury guibert delphine parent
etc miller sur des centaines de mètres
carrés voici le trésor de la communauté
emmaüs de bernes sur oise
il ya de tout et pour tout les goûts
ici s'était posée est libre voilà un
monsieur qui trient les div toute la
semaine et bat us est il un peu partout
- c'est le bric à brac te et tous les
jours ils sont nombreux à venir faire un
don le maître la tâche et ce sera non
pas de problème en revanche pour la cour
rien on est obligé quelques fois
d'expliquer qu' on ne peut prendre que
ce qui peut être revendables puisque
sinon on a des frais de décharge qui
sont élevés les ventes rapporte à cette
communauté un million d'euros tous les
ans que de chemin parcouru depuis les
débuts d'emmaüs
c'était dans cette maison de neuilly
plaisance près de paris en 1949
à l'époque l'idée de l'abbé pierre est
simple mais nouvelle revendre les objets
récupérés pour faire vivre les
compagnons aujourd'hui l'association
réalise un chiffre d'affaires de 115
millions d'euros et quelques coups
médiatiques comme il y a trois ans quand
elle lance une ligne de vêtements et
organisent des défilés de mode
emmaüs innove et sème à travers le monde
comme ici à londres
l'objectif est toujours le même
combattre l'exclusion si j'étais pas là
je serai mort la vérité c'est quand on
vit dehors sont baisse les bras
aujourd'hui l'oeuvre de l'abbé pierre se
poursuit dans une quarantaine de pays
pour comprendre comment est née la
vocation de l'abbé pierre il faut
plonger dans son enfance dans ses
racines à lyon où il était le cinquième
d'une famille de huit enfants
là bas il est resté henri grouès sur
place benoit gadret jean claude martin
le bénédicité repas de famille chez les
gros os
ici plus que l'abbé pierre c'est oncle
henri qui est atteint
nous sommes dans la maison familiale
d'irigny près de lyon la première vice
emmaüs y est sa deuxième vie c'est sa
famille est très proche très proche fait
partie de ces grandes qualités des
raisons pour lesquelles on les aime
beaucoup il est très proche de chacun
d'entre nous henri gros asséné dans le
quartier de la croix rousse à lyon
cinquième d'une fratrie de huit enfants
son père était administrateur de
sociétés j'étais un gosse de riche bon
et d'autres peurs très marquée par la
profondeur de la et la vérité de la vie
de foi qui était vécue par papa et maman
et l'efs chez les jésuites il brille
davantage par son charisme que par ses
résultats scolaires
j'ai pas être un bon élève j'ai eu même
un jour il n'y a pas un quart des notes
sur le cas l'udc avait écrit ce sont les
plus mauvaises notes de toul collège fut
henry n'avait pas fait frères et leurs
aumôniers sa vocation il la tient de son
père qui le dimanche s'engage auprès des
plus pauvres
le jeune adolescent découvre alors la
charité que voilà peut-être 30-40 je ne
sais plus vieux clochard mendiants
déguenillés salle et je vois c'est un
cri messieurs des amis de papa homme
d'affaires je m'appelle ingénieur à la
retraite et qui étaient les dimanches
matins les barbiers les coiffeurs des
plus miséreux l'abbé pierre revenait
régulièrement à lyon il aimait gravir la
colline de fourvière et contempler en
silence la ville de son enfance et il
faut se souvenir que c'est aussi un
catholique un prêtre qui disparaît
l'abbé pierre a beaucoup fait pour
l'église qui lui rend un hommage appuyé
aujourd'hui mais il l'a beaucoup
critiquée également nicolas chateauneuf
jean yves blanc entre l'abbé pierre et
l'église catholique
c'était une histoire de foi mais aussi
de liberté de ton et ses rencontres avec
jean paul ii qu'il admirait n'ont pas
empêché des prises de position très
différente de celle de l'église
j'ai été triste que le pape de paille
indiqué par exemple que dans un
territoire comme l'afrique actuellement
le préservatif deviennent légitimes
friable et le seul moyen
dans l'état actuel des moines capucins à
17 ans prêtera 19 toute sa vie la
vespière gardera une foi inébranlable
mais il n'épargnera pas l'église de ces
critiques que d'autres ont parfois payer
plus cher il était pas conformiste un
homme libre donc il n'avait pas peur de
dieu fait dire ça il ya ce si sûr il
avait la liberté encore une fois parce
qu'ils mettaient l'être humain au centre
donc c'est pas d'abord les lois s'était
pas d'avoir les règlements soient
d'abord ce qu'on pense qu'on dit les
religions s'ils s'en foutait pas mais il
allait au coeur de l'homme et il prenait
la part de cristal de l'homme du plus
pauvre au plus riche et ça c'était
fabuleux
autre motif de désaccord la des pierres
se prononce en faveur du mariage des
prêtres et de l'ordination des femmes
civ je ne vois pas de matériaux peuvent
absolument pas et pourtant l'église
française reconnaît aujourd'hui
l'héritage de l'abbé pierre
je pense que c'est un homme qui est
clairement donné au christ ça aussi ça
me touche beaucoup et ça me donne envie
de faire pareil je ne crois pas que ça
grâce première soit celle d'être un
théologien ou quelque chose comme ça à
la fin de sa vie l'abbé pierre aimait se
ressourcer dans le désert une manière de
retrouver la vie monacale de ses jeunes
années
sachez que france 2 consacre une soirée
spéciale à l'abbé pierre ce soir à 22h50
yves calvi et ses invités reviendront
sur son parcours son héritage et avant
cela vous pourrez suivre hiver 54 le
film de denis amar avec lambert wilson
dans le rôle de l'abbé pierre lambert
wilson qui a souvent affirmé que ce rôle
et ses rencontres à cette occasion avec
l'abbé avait changé sa vie abdelah
mostefa nicolas rend son cauchemar
nous on empêche un homme de sonner le
tocsin quand on meurt dans sa rue quatre
secondes c'est la scène emblématique
divers 54 l'appel du 1er février sur les
ondes de radio luxembourg
chaque nuit dans paris ils sont plus de
2000 a gelé dans la nuit sans toit sans
fin mal vêtu est malade
sur le plateau de tournage autour de
lambert wilson ce jour-là il y a bien
sûr l'équipe du film mais il ya aussi
l'abbé pierre qui souffre toujours là
j'étais totalement tétanisée il avait
cette générosité indulgente de voilà de
comprendre ma gêne et de se dire c'est
important que les gens réentendre à
nouveau ce message car pour lui les
chiffres n'avaient pas changé la
situation était la même voie et physique
complètement différent l'idée plaisait
beaucoup pas l'abbé pierre qui refusait
d'être idolâtré pour lui au delà de
l'émotion il devait y avoir des actes il
a obtenu le vote d'une loi l'abbé pierre
s'était pas simplement à une instruction
on apporter des couvertures et de
vêtements chauds
il a obtenu l'interdiction des
expulsions pendant la période hivernale
dans ma vie de citoyen il m'a ouvert les
yeux sur plein de choses et quand on
voit des gens dans la rue qui sont voilà
qui n'ont pas de logement qui sont
prouvé que c'était racines simplement on
les regarde et que on l'a fait
comprendre qu'on les a appréhendés
grande-côte que conques on sait qu'il
existe déjà on leur apporte une chose
essentielle qui est une identité
cet hiver-là l'abbé pierre est entré
dans le coeur des français
il n'en est jamais sortie depuis et je
vous rappelle donc vous pourrez suivre
en direct sur france2 l'hommage national
à l'abbé pierre vendredi à partir de
10h30
le reste de l'actualité est d'abord la
décision annoncée ce matin de nicolas
hulot il ne sera pas candidat à
l'élection présidentielle mais il entend
peser sur le débat
même s'il ne soutiendra aucun candidat
et les deux guides michael cariou au
milieu des photographes comme au coeur
de la nature
il est dans son élément nicholas pard si
monsieur hulot par là tiraillé depuis
des semaines entre y aller ou pas il a
mis fin au suspense
la gorge nouée j'ai décidé de ne pas
être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et de suspens donc mon
ingérence politique
la première raison la plus importante
revient à dire que j'ai choisi de faire
confiance à la parole et à l'engagement
des candidats
depuis cet été nicolas hulot alerte les
politiques sur les dangers que le
réchauffement climatique fait courir à
la planète en novembre entouré de
personnalités du show business et des
sciences il lance son pacte écologique
succès populaire un demi million de
signatures recueillies et surtout
victoire politique
les candidats s'en empare tous à
l'exception des extrêmes le signe il
promet de rester vigilant je leur
demande de maintenir jusqu'au deuxième
tour
l'impératif écologique comme le thème
majeur de débat et de réflexion
je leur demande de ne pas oublier la
question de la biodiversité tout aussi
crucial que celle des changements
climatiques milliers dès l'annoncé du
retrait de nicolas hulot le camp
écologiste se disputent l'héritage pour
je puisse pacte écologique ressemble
comme un clown à au programme de voile
et des verts espérons qu'il puisse y
avoir un transfert disons d'amour et de
voir nicolas hulot a soulevé une
espérance formidable c'est à moi de la
transformer sur le terrain nicolas hulot
quitte la scène politique
regret peut soulager ses failles
décision forcément facile à prendre
pas candidat mais il ne s'interdit pas
de refaire la leçon écologique à tous
les prétendants à l'elysée alors c'est
une nouvelle donne dans la campagne en
direct du quartier général des verts
nous retrouvons dominique voynet
candidate précisément des verts votre
réaction dominique voynet on imagine que
vous êtes soulagé tout d'abord un
immense respect pour nicolas parce que
je pense que cette décision était
difficile à prendre
quand on est crédité 10% des intentions
de vote on doit être vraiment tenté il
faut beaucoup de force de caractère et
beaucoup de fois dans ses idées je crois
pour renoncer
et puis un passage de témoin mais je
sens comme ça je crois que nicolas va
rester vigilant mais que c'est à nous
désormais qu'il incombe de reprendre le
chantier
je veux dans cette campagne trop côté de
ce peuple de l'écologie qui la décrit je
veux dans cette campagne et aux côtés de
ceux qui luttent pour des projets
dévastateur et ruineux contre les
incinérateurs qui mine notre santé et
crache du carbone contre les coins du
str et contre l'autre l'agro industrie
franchement il ya beaucoup de travail à
faire alors vous dites passage de témoin
mais nicolas hulot annonce qu'il ne
soutiendra personne vous êtes déçus par
cette décision mais je comprends ça
c'est le prix de la crédibilité de son
engagement j'ai noté aussi qu'il a
toujours précisé qu'il n'entendait pas
faire de mal aux verts et qu'il a salué
le travail des élus écologistes dans les
assemblées ce matin il dit que ça a pesé
dans sa décision je me sens investie
cette responsabilité je veux aussi
puisque nous sommes en train
effectivement de déplorer la mort de
l'abbé pierre dire que je serai dans
cette campagne
attentives aux mesures qui seront prises
pour lutter contre la pauvreté parce
qu'il n'est pas possible parler
d'écologie aux plus fragiles aux plus
modestes à ceux qui aujourd'hui
subissent augmentation du prix des
logements
sans répondre à leurs questions
quotidiennes alors dernière chose vous
le disiez il était crédité de 10 % des
intentions de vote pour vous c'est 2%
est ce que ça ne remet pas en cause
votre manière de faire de la politique
dominique voynet
je crois que l'acte en direction nicolas
hulot n'était pas tout à fait celle qui
existe aujourd'hui en direction des
verts je veux retenir une seule chose
c'est une nouvelle phase de la campagne
qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui je suis plein
d'espoir très motivé je sais que nous
pouvons faire autrement nous avons
vas y et réfléchie depuis 20 ans aux
solutions à proposer la société et je
crois qu'elle est mûr pour nous entendre
donc je suis vraiment plein d'énergie et
de force pour mener cette campagne
merci merci dominique bonnet d'avoir
répondu à nos questions vous étiez en
direct du quartier général des verts
encore un mode politique ségolène royal
a inauguré aujourd'hui le siège de sa
campagne présidentielle au parti
socialiste une tente transparente a été
installé dans les locaux rue de
solférino à paris le lieu sera ouvert au
public et à cette occasion elle a
annoncé une accélération des débats
participatifs c'est sans doute une
manière de répondre aux critiques plus
ou moins feutrée de ces derniers jours
la synthèse nationale de ce débat aura
lieu vous le savez les 10 et 11 février
un mois tout juste après le début après
la fin de l'automne l'hiver arrive enfin
les températures vont chuter cette
semaine la neige est attendue sur un
tiers du pays météo france lance
d'ailleurs une alerte orange pour la
nuit dans une trentaine de départements
du centre et de l'est des vosges à la
drôme où l'on pourrait se réveiller avec
15 cm de poudreuse en plaine les
saleuses sont prêtes images ici de la
creuse près de guéret où les stocks de
sel ont déjà été vérifiée
la neige qui est arrivé déjà sur les
plateaux espagnols et même en plaine
images de galice et de la région de
ségovie où plusieurs écoles sont restées
fermées aujourd'hui l'arrivée de l'hiver
qui risque de gêner un peu plus les
opérations de pompage du
porte-conteneurs napoli au large des
côtes britanniques
en tout cas vous allez le voir le
malheur des uns fait le bonheur des
autres
on s'est rué sur les plages depuis hier
pour récupérer la marchandise tombé du
bateau sur place reportage maryse burgot
dominique marault tél
un imbroglio de conteneurs éventré
d'objets les plus divers recraché par la
mer et à moins d'un kilomètre de ce site
classé de la baie de lyme
le msc napoli et s'agite impressionnante
sur la plage souillée
les habitants du coin ramasse tout ce
qu'ils trouvent des cosmétiques des
pièces dé passer de voiture dépassée
aliments pour chats que l'on va chercher
jusqu'à l'intérieur des conteneurs fait
l'exploit prévoir ce qu'il ya sur le
marché
on prend que ce qui peut rapporter de la
shopping onguents en terre parfaitement
légal ces jeunes gens ont trouvé une
moto ils l'ont signalé à la police
maintenant ils peuvent la prendre
les habitants subissent un grand
préjudice avec cette pollution
au moins cela leur fait la compensation
si l'armateur ne la réclame pas cette
moto appartiendra à celui qu'il a trouvé
comme d'ailleurs tous ces objets croyez
que vous alliez l'envoyer en france vous
avez préféré nul expédiés merci beaucoup
ces bâtiments français qui ont remorqué
le navire sont d'ailleurs toujours l'un
un troisième renfort vient d'arriver de
charbon ce que nous voyons sur cette
plage représentent une infime partie de
la cargaison s'est tous les conteneurs
tombait à l'eau ce serait évidemment
beaucoup plus grave et c'est pour éviter
cela car navire français spécialisé dans
le remorquage des conteneurs va venir
prêter main forte aux autorités
britanniques
en bref encore à l'étranger un double
attentat à la voiture piégée à bagdad a
fait 88 morts et plus de 160 blessés
c'est l'attaqué la plus meurtrière
depuis le début de l'année là bas elle
intervient alors que les etats-unis ont
commencé à déployer des renforts dans la
capitale
les premiers représailles de l'iran
après les sanctions contre son programme
nucléaire téhéran a décidé d'interdire
l'accès de son territoire autres en a
trente huit inspecteurs de l'agencé de
l'énergie atomique qui mène des visites
dans les installations
et puis les résultats des élections en
serbie avec la victoire mais victoire
paradoxale des ultra nationalistes qui
sont crédités de 28% des voix ils sont
en tête mais ne pourront pas gouverner
les partis démocratiques vont tenter de
former une alliance pour mettre sur pied
un gouvernement pro européen
en france un procès très attendu à
bobigny celui d'une filière de vente de
bébés des parents en mal d'adoption
acheter des nourrissons à des femmes
bulgares yasmina farber stéphane
guilbaud ce couple affiche avec fierté
la photo de leur fille le vb qu'ils ont
acheté plus loin ceux là préfèrent
rester discrets quarante personnes
issues du milieu gitans sont poursuivis
pour provocations à l'abandon d'un
enfant tous ont payé pour avoir un
nourrisson des intermédiaires lors donné
les conditions c'est sur un corner de
l'école apprendre à venir romande
on se reverra voyez entre vérin et la
parlement de partir sadate qui manie les
unions gays recensé six mille euros et
5000 euros
johnny devait acheter le bébé de gingka
prostituée bulgare et de son compagnon
les policiers les ont interrompu en
pleine transaction dans le parking d'une
maternité parisienne
il découvre un trafic organisé votre
show un vieux gitans repère des couples
en mal d'enfant des proxénètes propose
le marché à des prostituées enceinte
quand cette époque le mec qui vous fait
la proposition à l'aide du mal à nous
opposer à ça parce que l'un ne va pas
sans l'autre
quand on peut vous lui apprenez votre
enfant de après p12 misère qui se
rencontrent prostituée bulgare et gitans
français aux antipodes des critères
d'adoption
on touche la frontière entre le droit et
la morale
je crois qu'elle a une prise de
conscience qui doit avoir lieu en france
sur les critères très restrictifs
d'adoption sur 22 bébés vins sont restés
dans les familles des acheteurs ils sont
bien traités
les parents encourent trois ans de
prison pour avoir falsifié l'état civil
des enfants ce sont les intermédiaires
qui risque gros
dix ans de prison pour traite des êtres
humains dans l'actualité également il
n'y a pas que le bâtiment qui manquent
de bras l'armée de terre a donné
aujourd'hui le coup d'envoi d'une grande
campagne de recrutement dans les
journaux à la télévision à la radio sur
internet une publicité massive
cette année près de 13000 postes sont à
pourvoir
tu lui as delage patrie ça serait et
dire qu'à 20 ans pour l volet n'était
qu'un rêve aujourd'hui melli casamatta
et capitaine de l'armée de terre pilote
sur puma et gazelle et depuis peu
instructrice lorsque je me suis engagé
j'avais pour le pape je pensais pas
pouvoir accéder à cette formation
il faut de la motivation et puis et puis
aussi beaucoup de travail
et puis un parcours exemplaire que
l'armée vente dans ce spot publicitaire
pour recruter treize mille nouveaux
jeunes soldats cette année appelez le 32
40 dit armée de terre aujourd'hui
l'armée se place en concurrence avec le
secteur privé alors il faut attirer les
plus diplômés et la bataille n'est pas
toujours facile alors qu'on s'entende
bien l'armée de terre cecafa métier
mettez des rendements celui de mai
l'armée fait encore rêver certains et
les militaires ont d'autres arguments
ce qui va encadrer des personnes
carencées en tant que grade de sergent
après une période sur la version mobile
quelques mois important
ben je vais partir en mission truc dans
l'armée chacun a sa chance
l'ascenseur social existe la moitié de
nos officiers viennent sont rentrés un
jour comme sous-officier la moitié de
nos sous-officier sont rentrés un jour
comme militaires du rang mais pour les
recruteurs de l'armée le principal
problème reste le nerf de la guerre
l'argent
les meilleurs éléments préfère des
postes dans le privé bien mieux rémunéré
deux mots de sport avec d'abord le
football la coupe de france et le choc
des 8e de finale marseille sera opposé à
lyon le tirage au sort avait lieu dans
la soirée hier
nantes lille psg valenciennes monaco
sochaux total quatre matches opposeront
des clubs de ligue 1 le petit poucet de
la compétition vous le voyez sera opposé
à bordeaux il s'agit de
montceau-les-mines et puis l'image du
week-end comme chaque lundi c'est ce
match dans des conditions apocalyptiques
en afrique du sud
des vents de 100km ont arraché les
panneaux publicitaires sur le bord du
terrain
mettant en danger les joueurs comme le
public à ce match du championnat
national n'a pu d'ailleurs être terminée
l'orage et la pluie ont fini par pousser
les équipes aux vestiaires fin de ce
journal
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo laurent romejko qui nous confirme
l'arrivée de la neige puis soirée
spéciale abbé-pierre donc avec dans
quelques instants hiver 54 avec lambert
wilson à demain
nous non
nous hésitions